こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
今日は、
卍（まんじ）
あの基本遊戯王カードの動画
僕サブチャンネルにしか出さないんですけども、
今日は堂々と!メインチャンネルで！私はじめしゃちょーが、
（拍手）
で、どんな大会かと言いますと
その公式の...公認の大会がありましてね
その...遊戯王が作ってる会社が認めた、
店舗...お店で行われる
店舗大会みたいな物があって、
今回それに参加してきます！
ドンッ（机を叩く）
どれだけ頑張ったことか！
俺はこの大会の為に！
昨日の夜？？？ぐらい？？？から！
少しずつショップに行って！
デュエリストの友達たちと、考え、試行錯誤し！
ようやく完成させた私のガエルデッキで、今回は
大会で、どこまで行けるのか？
皆さんに、お見せしようと思います。
もう負けたらそこで終了の大会ですからね。
何人来るかもちょっとわからないし、
もう結果がどうなるかわからないんですけども
今日は！
この最高の日曜日に、大会に言ってこようと思います!
ホントに結構色々と考えたんですよ今回。
何回か大会は出たことがあるんですけど今回割と本気で結構考えたデッキなので、
これで負けたら僕はそこまでの人間ですよ。
だけど運もあるんで一概に勝てると言えないんですけれども、
簡単に言いましょう。
私のデッキは、カエルを使って嫌がらせデッキです。
一応この子がメインになるのかな?
この子が私の的な主人公餅ガエルちゃんです。
この子を使って相手にどこまで嫌がらせを出来るかが僕のデッキの戦い方の勝利
トラップカードっていう相手を騙せるカードをたくさん入れているんで、
そこで、どこまで相手に嫌がらせを出来るかが今回の戦いの秘訣になっております。
ジャンケンで勝てば、多分勝てます。
今の遊戯王ですね、色んなデッキが輝けるんで
色んな敵が居るんでその中で上手いこと対策して勝たなきゃいけないという訳で
果たしてはじめしゃちょーはどれほど遊戯王カードが強いのか今回皆様にお見せしようと思います。
俺は頑張ってきた。
構築を考え、
色んな場面を想定し、
色んなカードをゆりて、
ここまでやってきた。
いざ、参れ!
と言うわけで、
ショップに来ました。
一応、店長さんにも許可取って
一応、動画を撮れることになったので
ちょっと大会で
どこまでいけるか
今日は！
やっていきたいと思います！
では、行こ
優勝しました…！
やったああああああああああああああ！！！
〜♪エンディング〜